and welcome to hannity day two of jury
deliberations in the trial of kyle
rittenhouse it is now officially in the
books and still no verdict now earlier
today an explosive new development from
the courthouse and it all surrounds this
drone footage showing kyle rittenhouse
shooting joseph rosenbaum in what looks
like a clear act of self-defense
according to one eyewitness account
rosenbaum threatened written house
telling him quote i'm going to bleeping
kill you oh that would be a threat then
as you can see right there rosenbaum
chased rittenhouse threw an object at
his head cornered him against a group of
parked cars and then lunged for the
written house's weapon before
rittenhouse discharged his firearm
killing rosenbaum now a new reason for a
potential mistrial is that the defense
team did not get this high quality video
until it was shown in court instead
during discovery they were emailed a
compressed low-quality version in what
the prosecution is calling quote a bid
to undermine written house's
self-defense this is now the second
mistrial request one with prejudice and
one without under consideration
by the judge now keep in mind the judge
will not likely make a decision until
after a verdict has been rendered so
there's a big question mark here if
rittenhouse is found not guilty there
will be no point in declaring a mistrial
ultimately there are now multiple
legitimate reasons for a possible
mistrial with several instances of
alleged prosecutorial misconduct
including criticizing the defendant's
right to remain silent aligning the
defendant's right to face his accusers
violating an order banning prior gun
comments and now failure to turn over
video evidence as the law requires our
very own greg jarrett who will join us
in a moment he'll have a lot more detail
on why a mistrial is a definite
possibility in this case and meanwhile
according to the mob and the media top
democrats kyle rittenhouse is already
guilty he was guilty from day one no
trial no due process no presumption of
innocence just lock them up throw away
the key according to joy reed over at
msdnc rittenhouse does not deserve the
presumption of innocence because of his
white male tears
what nbc news actually said this
apparently they did take a look
in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right
they carry out and then as soon as you
get caught
green water works
[Music]
white men can get away with that too
it's stunning katie this feels like
those cases in the 1950s where it was in
and out in and out you know somebody
white male killed someone and they were
in and out fast and acquitted that's how
it feels
to me
yikes but there is more joy reid also
went on the attack against the judge and
impugned his character take a look
but as long as the judge appears to be
tipping the scales of justice in
rittenhouse's favor the public may not
have confidence in the process or the
verdict well that is a question i've had
too kate i mean is there any recourse
this judge
has done everything but you know offered
to adopt gal right now like he seems so
clearly
on his side does the prosecution have
any recourse if it seems so clear that
the judge has already made up his mind
the kyle rittenhouse he's honest it
seems at least to the to the lay person
out there that he's completely on his
side
the hysteria and anger the rush to
judgment from joy reid many of her
colleagues and the media mob is so bad
that today the judge addressed this very
issue in court take a look
when i talked about
[Music]
problems with the media when this trial
started
that's
we're there in part not not fully but in
part because of grossly irresponsible
handling of what comes out of this trial
i will tell you this uh i'm gonna think
long and hard about uh live television
the trial again next time i don't know i
i've always been a firm believer in it
because i think the people should be
able to see what's going on but when i
see what's being done it's really quite
frightening frightening that's the right
word there are reports tonight that the
judge has received hundreds of vile
messages since this trial has begun
including death threats to his entire
family and then to make matters worse
all week long a crowd of protesters
gathered outside of the courthouse many
of them pledging to riot and commit acts
of violence if written houses found not
guilt is not found guilty now after what
we witnessed in 2020 we have no reason
to believe that they won't back up that
threat now just imagine for a second how
terrifying this has got to be for
members of this jury that are trying to
be fair trying to follow the law 12 law
abiding americans fulfilling a
constitutional duty taking it with all
the seriousness they can they now are
face to face with an angry mob that in
all likelihood they're hearing with
their very own ears this is what happens
when powerful people in the media in
washington in the swamp when they rush
to judgment and sadly it happens every
single time over and over again the same
cast of characters the media mob they
get it wrong and innocent people they
pay the price richard jewell darren
wilson george zimmerman duke lacrosse
uva baltimore nicolas sandman the
covington high school kids and on and on
and on same people same people every
single time americans smeared besmirch
their character assassinated their lives
ruined all because liberals care more
about optics and a political narrative
than they care about something called
truth and justice and our constitution
and i don't know what is going to happen
in the case of kyle rittenhouse you
really can't ever judge what a jury is
going to do but for my position based on
all the video evidence all the
eyewitness testimony this looks like a
very clear-cut case of self-defense
according to wisconsin law and now it is
in the hands of the jury they will
render a verdict any violence any
writing that follows well you can thank
the media mob you can even thank joe
biden the president of the united states
he recklessly referred to kyle
rittenhouse as a white supremacist
months before the trial ever started
with not an iota of evidence to back up
that claim he's never apologized either
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else